[Music]
good evening everyone
welcome to the table we're so glad to
join you here
and um just grateful for this space
together
together to worship um excited to pray
for you
and to listen to what brett has to share
tonight as well
um i have a couple of announcements
actually tonight to kick
us off with for those of you who are
part of our email list or
brett's weekly text you might have
already seen this but
tonight is our quarterly table
um oh gosh uh state of the table sorry i
lost my wording there for a minute our
state of the table meeting
that happens at 6 15 so about 15 minutes
after we finish this service
we'll be logging on there to a google
meets together
and it's a time for the leadership and
those who are serving
to kind of share and reflect on what
god's been doing
and not only for the past but also
looking ahead at what's coming
up and really our goal is
to um not only fill you in
but be transparent and accountable and
in every way that we can
so we welcome you to that if you're
interested or feel like this is
um a place that you call home
please join us we will be sending out
the link at the end of this service
we'll be posting it in the chat below so
and be watching for that um towards the
end tonight and we'll make sure to get
you that information
to that google meets is is our platform
for that
um one other thing we just wanted to
mention so that you could save the date
and put it on your calendar
our table book club led by glenda bayron
and sarah johns
is um scheduled on the calendar for
march 13th at 10 a.m that will be a
virtual meetup this
month um but the book they have chosen i
believe is called
cast and that's written let me look at
my notes here
isabelle wilkerson i actually don't know
her but um
i've heard from them that this is
supposed to be an exciting book
so they plan to actually discuss
the first three parts of the book
together
at this month's book club so it won't be
an extensive conversation over the
entirety of the book
so no worries if you're just getting
started or you haven't read the whole
thing
that's totally fine come and join in on
the conversation
this is open to um all ages and
all um genders so we would love to have
you there
and um i know glinda and sarah are both
just
very thoughtful people committed to
challenging themselves and opening
themselves up to the experiences
and um and the worlds of other people so
that's a this is a good space to do that
um in the community of friends um
i'm going to go ahead and begin
transitioning us to our service
i was reading um about a story in the
book of mark
where jesus is sitting um at a dinner
party
and kind of reclining at the table and
in the story it was describing
the different roles that people had you
know so-and-so was um
serving and so and so was reclining at
the table and this person came and did
this
and as it listed it i couldn't help in
my mind but think of
the table our table that exists here and
think of
us gathering at the table with jesus
and it hit me as i'm reading this story
and
thinking of the lives of those
individuals that it was naming you know
it
it happened to name mary and it named
martha and it named lazarus
and i thought of our community you know
i thought of mindy and i thought of
brittany
and i thought of adam and i thought of
carter and josh and
you know just all the different faces
out there
i thought of our kids i thought of just
everyone who
um comes and gathers with us at this
table and i thought
we all have our stories we all come into
the room and we come to this table
with a different past um
and even different present
you know each one of us is living a
different life and we're coming
to this table to meet with jesus and
each other
and um that can be a lot
to take in you know and sometimes it can
even be hard
to be present because of everything else
that was happening
outside of this moment and so
i just wanted us to together as a
community
just take a moment to take a deep breath
in and slowly release it
a couple of times and then i just want
to
be quiet for a moment and say a prayer
as we transition over to mindy and the
other worship team members who are
leading us tonight
and really allow ourselves to bring
all of that to the table with jesus
because one thing that i love is that he
doesn't ask us to leave those parts of
ourselves behind when we come to him
he has space for all of it and um
so let's enter into that space together
go ahead and
breathe in and out for a moment
let me pray
god i give you thanks for each person
each story each life represented here
and i thank you even more so that you
are
so familiar and acquainted with every
minute
detail of it there's not a single moment
of it that has escaped
your knowing
and god we bring all of ourselves before
you
and asks that in that space you could
allow us to come into contact
with the god who sees us
and whatever you have for us tonight
lord we open our hearts to that
and we give you space to move
and to to work
to heal and encourage
to bless to correct to challenge
but most of all we just open ourselves
up to you
and leave every shame and every burden
that might hinder us from fully showing
up
we leave that at the floor
in jesus name we pray amen
hey guys um thank you maggie that
was a perfect introduction into our next
little section here because
this week um i was so grateful carter
reached out to me and asked if he could
share a song that's just been
ministering to him and
ministering is such a fancy word isn't
it um
but yeah i think that's what it was so
i asked him if he would give us a little
blurb a little
insight
is that better can you guys hear me
sorry guys
let's see okay scott
can we just switch for right now back to
maggie's
and look at us
this is gonna be this is when it's handy
that we live together
okay uh
are we all good i think
hopefully okay all right yay got it good
okay
so um anyways i just encouraged
carter i was like could you give us a
window into your world and what it's
been like because he's kind of been in
some unique
situations um and
then josh brock also i'd ask him to
contribute a song and then
he sends me this video where he's kind
of like sharing a window into his heart
for the song and i just thought you know
what when it comes to church it's so
easy
sometimes especially whenever you're on
the
um like organizational side of the
service like okay we're gonna do this
and we're gonna do that
it's so easy sometimes to get caught up
at least for me
um into like the practicals and the
nitty-gritty
but when we strip all that away like
what is church because you can still
have church without any of
this you know what i mean we don't have
to have um
a certain format we don't have to have a
certain presentation we don't have to
have a certain order
even you know those things can be
helpful to make it more accessible for
us as a community
but at the end of the day it's about
community it's about people
it's about coming together and sharing
our stories
and getting the mess and the muck of all
of it in the same room or sometimes on
the same screen virtually or
you know however it is that we come
together as people that's where we
experience
jesus that's where we get to see our
faith take shape like that's where we
get to actually
work out our faith um so anyways i was
just thinking like man
if you don't like people good luck
finding a church because that is church
church is people so anyways i
just love what maggie was saying we're
gonna just have a few little moments
here with carter and then with joshua
they're just letting us into a window
of their hearts and their lives so
anyways i hope that you guys just enjoy
hearing from their um hearing their
stories
hearing from other people in our
community who we don't always get the
opportunity to hear from
so thank you guys for making space for
that and we're gonna go ahead and
get to scott i mean scott will get to
carter's video
hi before i do this next song
i'm gonna do eye of the storm i wanted
to
tell you about uh my experience of the
the week of the winter storm that uh
that
hit us all that we you know i have a lot
of friends that's
uh had problems in their homes pipes
broke
water froze they're having to do repairs
in their home they're kind of in the
recovery stage
i have other friends that had terrible
conditions they they
lost power but luckily they escaped any
kind of damage to their homes and
they're kind of they're getting back to
normal
and and some people i know uh didn't
have any
power lost at all and they uh you know
they had you know had to deal with the
cold and snow but you know some of them
you know had fun in the snow and it's
kind of strange how
we all experienced we all were hit with
the same challenges in some regards i
guess they're the same elements
but uh we all had different experiences
and uh mine was unique in that i would i
had one foot in the
everything is okay world and
one foot in the nothing is okay world at
home
we did not lose power everything was
fine
uh we didn't have any mechanical
failures or pipes break
and that was great at work
a different story if anything could go
wrong
it did go wrong and i spent the better
part of a
week at work without coming home and
it was a blessing that i didn't have to
worry about my family and my house
while i was dealing with things at work
and uh anything that you
can imagine went wrong you know and
pipes breaking
what not you know times 100 it it did we
had uh temperatures got below freezing
in the buildings and the
water the water that leaked frozen on
the floors and walking areas and
stairwells and
uh just it's a it was a pretty intense
and
uh and there were some great great
stories that came out of that as well i
work with some great people and a lot of
people rose to the occasion and
it was just amazing but it was tough at
the same time
and um i have this bible that
is was in my desk when i started working
there four and a half years ago
and i'll open it up occasionally and uh
that last week
i said well let me see what the bible
has in store for me
and um the first thing my eyes fell on
was psalm 27
and uh before i read it um
it talks about enemies and foes and uh
to me uh it wasn't a
you know literal enemy or person or
people that
coming against me but to me the enemy
was more figurative it was the storm it
was the cold elements that were
invading into where i was at and
attacking
and so psalm 27 goes
the lord is my light and my salvation
whom shall i fear
the lord is the strength of my life of
whom shall i be afraid
when the wicked came against me to eat
up my flesh my enemies and foes they
stumbled and fell
though an army may encamp against me my
heart shall not fear
the war may rise against me in this i
will be confident
one thing i have desired of the lord
that will i seek
that i may dwell in the house of the
lord all the days of my life
to behold the beauty of the lord and to
inquire in his temple
for in time of trouble he shall hide me
in his pavilion
in the secret place of his tabernacle he
shall hide me
he shall set me high upon a rock
so i left the bible open to that psalm
and i would look at it periodically
throughout the week and it
really helped get me through gave me
strength gave me
you know perseverance and and uh and so
this song
that i'm going to do i have the storm
was also i've heard on the radio it's
playing in the back uh playing in my
head
um very similar lyrical
themes uh so uh
here we go
in the eye of the storm
you remain in control
in the middle of the war you got my soul
you alone are the anchor when my sails
are dark
your love surrounds me
in the eye of the storm
when the solid ground is falling out
from underneath my feet between the
black skies and the red
eyes i can barely see
when i'm feeling like i've been let down
by my friends and my family
i can hear the rain reminding me
[Music]
you alone are the anchor when my sails
are torn
your love surrounds me in the eye of the
song
[Music]
when my hopes and dreams far from me
i'm running out of faith to see the
future
i pictured slowly fade away
when the tears were pain and hearty
pouring down my face i find my peace in
jesus name
in the eye of the storm i remain in
control
in the middle of the storm you got my
soul
you alone are the anchor when my soul is
torn
your love surrounds me
[Music]
when they let me go i just don't know
how it makes me i did my best now i'm
scared the death
meaningless everything when the darkness
crosses
on me i feel there's nothing i can do
my only hope
[Music]
surrounds me in the eye of the storm
you alone are the anchor when my sails
are tall
love surrounds me in the eye of the
storm
[Music]
me
in the eye of the storm your love
surrounds me
hey fam uh welcome to the table
another sunday night online
um yeah i really miss you guys
um but before i sing i want to tell a
story about a story that i heard this
week
and how it connected to the song that
i'm going to sing
so i'm practicing this song it's called
the father's house
and uh playing it never never played it
before
and i just realized it's getting me in
my feels
uh which is not abnormal for me uh but
it's abnormal for me to talk about it
getting me in my feels so um there's
that
um but what i realized when i was
playing it
is that it was because of a story that
was told to me this week somebody shared
part of their story part of their
journey
and it involved hardship um brokenness
but in the end joy-filled because of
this community
the table and i realized playing this
song that
that story was so powerful and it
impacted me
and i'm so thankful that this person was
able to share
their heart and part of their story
so as i play the song just take in the
words think about your own journey
think about what the table has meant to
you this community
of loving people that's inclusive and we
want no one left out
um yeah think about that
and uh i don't know i see what happens
[Music]
right
sometimes on this journey
i get lost in my mistakes looks to me
like
weakness is a canvas for your strength
and my story isn't over
the story's just
i begun you won't define me
cause that's what my father does
feel your want to find me
[Music]
check your
here in the father's house
[Music]
rivals
and the story isn't over
if the story isn't good
failures when the father is never
[Music]
here in the father's house
check your shame at the door
it ain't welcome
in the anymore house
[Music]
is
here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
is
[Music]
here in the father's house
check your shame at the
[Music]
here in the father's house
check your shame at the door
it ain't welcome anymore
[Music]
love is on
love is breaking through when the father
thanks josh good evening everyone
welcome grace and peace it's
really really great to be with you as
always so this
is uh part two in our series titled lent
from repentance to renewal and uh i gave
a
kind of a bit of a longer introduction
to lent in my message last week
so if you missed that you can go back
and listen to it on our podcast but
uh just to try and sum it up lent is is
basically a season
uh that leads up to good friday uh that
of course is the day of jesus
um crucifixion and then on to easter
so it's kind of a season of spiritual
preparation
uh and traditionally christians took uh
or continue to take the 40 days of lent
to either engage a new spiritual
discipline
or to give something up that their
that kind of that part of us that ego
that false self um kind of craves
whether it's
i don't know the lots of additional tv
time or chocolate or meat or you know
whatever it is you find yourself
um kind of self-medicating with
that's kind of what lent is about is
that that season of spiritual
preparation purification
um as we approach uh holy week so
uh with that in mind the title of my
message on this second sunday of
lent is you are not
a thing you are not a thing
uh and that leads me right to my big
idea for tonight which is this
you are not a thing you are a temple
a house of divinity
so it may seem at points as we go
through this message that i have lost
sight
of this central insight do not worry i
will come back to it i promise i've not
forgotten
so just a heads up on that and then
finally our primary text
uh is going to be exodus chapter 20 uh
verses 1 through 17
and this is of course the passage where
the famous 10 commandments
are found and so our very own
marissa martinez she's gonna go ahead
and
read that for us tonight so marissa
go for it
and god spoke all these words i'm the
lord your god
who brought you out of egypt out of the
land of slavery
you shall have no other gods before me
you shall not make for yourself an image
in the form of anything in heaven above
or on the earth beneath
or in the waters below you shall not bow
down to them or worship them
for i the lord your god am a jealous god
punishing the children for the sin of
the parents to the third and fourth
generation of those who hate me
but showing love to a thousand
generations of those who love me and
keep my commandments
you shall not misuse the name of the
lord your god for the lord will not hold
anyone guiltless who misuses his name
remember the sabbath day by keeping it
holy
six days you shall labor and do all your
work but the seventh day
is a sabbath to the lord your god on it
you shall not do any work
neither you nor your son or daughter
nor your male or female servant nor your
animals
nor any foreigner residing in your towns
for in six days the lord made the
heavens and the earth
the sea and all that is in them but he
rested on the seventh day
therefore the lord blesses the sabbath
day and made it holy
honor your father and your mother so
that you may live long in the land the
lord your god is giving you
you shall not murder you shall not
commit adultery
you shall not steal you shall not give
false testimony against your neighbor
you shall not covet your neighbor's
house you shall not covet your
neighbor's wife
or his male or female servant his ox or
donkey
or anything that belongs to your
neighbor
thanks marissa uh so here's the question
that i'd like to begin with why
is something right or wrong
what makes it so so i'm nearly done
uh with a book by jonathan height titled
the righteous mind
why good people are divided by politics
and religion and height is a social
psychologist who teaches at new york
university
and uh it's an excellent read really
insightful but one of the things that he
studies
is what people believe is right and
wrong
and just as importantly um why
they believe something is right or wrong
so it's it's kind of the what in the why
of ethics
and now to this end he's very fond of
questionnaires
with difficult moral conundrums that he
kind of presents to folks um now he has
a lot online there's like a website i
think it's yourmorals.org or something
like that you can go and take some as
questionnaires
um but back in like his graduate uh
school days he would just go to
mcdonald's
in like you know random places upper
class
you know kind of working class places
just anywhere and he'd go to mcdonald's
and he'd set up and like ask people if
they would engage his questionnaires
because he's kind of you know he needs
data as a social scientist and a
psychologist so
um here's a few questions uh or a few
kind of examples of the types of
questions he would include
uh and these are like actual ones from
his questionnaires now
i should warn you they can be a little
bit disturbing um
although i haven't i've intentionally
edited some of the more extreme ones
and karen and mindy uh reviewed some of
these questions and they gave me
feedback like yeah don't include that
one so
i haven't included them all but here's a
few um they're still a little bit
disturbing
um now notice though it's on purpose
because basically he needs to get a rise
out of people so to speak he needs to
stir up our righteous indignation
uh so all right here's the first one
a family dog was killed
by a car in front of their house
they had heard that dog meat was
delicious
so they cut up the dog's body and they
cooked it
and ate it for dinner was that wrong
why yeah
like i said uh more than a little
disturbing all right here's another
example this one isn't quite as extreme
i don't think but
still not it's not it's not great all
right so uh here it is a woman
was cleaning out her closet and she
finds her old american flag
she doesn't want the flag anymore so she
cuts it up into pieces
and uses the rags to clean her bathroom
was that wrong why
now it's likely uh that regardless
of i mean almost anything like your
religious upbringing
um cultural background political
affiliation
um i mean regardless of all that you
probably had a certain
kind of quick gut reaction to
those stories uh i mean in story number
one
the family kind of did something you
know kind of morally like uh
disgusting and then in story number two
the lady did something probably kind of
triggered more of like a disrespect you
know you think like uh
i think you should do that um so we have
these gut reactions
what height points out is uh the trouble
comes when
when we try to explain why like when we
try to give a kind of a logic
uh you see he's a very clever
psychologist because he crafts these
stories to make it abundantly clear
um that no one was hurt at least
intentionally like in the process
for example if the story you know went
that the family killed their dog
and then ate it well then we'd say like
whoa you can't
murder your pet right but the moral
conundrum
becomes when it's already hit and killed
by a car
well but still something in us says like
i
don't think you should eat your pet but
then we're kind of left scratching our
heads when we try to explain
why uh or i mean perhaps we just resort
to an emotional
well you just can't do that uh but you
know of course that's not like
much of an explanation um in other words
we have these
moral intuitions these gut reactions of
what is right and what is wrong
but our problem uh becomes explaining
why these types of moral conundrums are
wrong and the reason we're baffled and
trying to explain why is because the
great
foundation of modern uh
western ethics uh and that would include
of course america
is that something is wrong because
it hurts someone else like that's
kind of the lens through which we view
ethics so it's a thing is wrong
when it hurts someone else um or hurts
even a person
like even us so height what he did
though is he intentionally
crafted stories that would strike our
instincts as wrong but deprived us
of our go-to reasoning uh in fact he
said it was really fascinating to watch
people try and come up with
the why with the reason um when he was
doing these questionnaires
because basically they were trying to
figure out how someone actually was hurt
so for example they would say things
like i mean uh
well you you you can't eat dog
right isn't that isn't that bad for you
i've heard i think
i think you'll get sick isn't it right i
think you'll get even though of course
there's like countries all over the
world where people eat dog um but that's
you know
what are they doing they're they're
trying to come back to this foundation
of not harming someone or something
uh so he unpacked this in more detail
by citing a totally different ethicist
named dr richard schweiter
and schweiter he says there are three
great moral themes
in human culture again hang with me i
promise i have not forgotten about the
ten commandments
all right so three great moral themes
number one the ethic
of autonomy autonomy here
means moral independence this is the
idea
that i can do whatever i want as long as
i do not hurt anyone else right sounds
familiar because that's what we were
just talking about
uh previously so um in other words as
long as i do not infringe
upon someone else's rights upon their
freedoms
uh you know i'm good but the moment i
hurt someone else okay
then it's wrong then i've gone too far
and this ethic of autonomy
uh is as i named just a moment ago the
absolute foundation of our moral
reasoning in the west
both left right and center politically
speaking we
we use the ethic of autonomy to justify
why something is right or wrong
and this is why height crafted his
stories to deprive
poor people like us of that explanation
and then we just sort of sit there
floundering like i don't know why you
can't eat your
dead dog but it seems very wrong to me
however schweder points out that most of
the world
would not at all want to stop here at
the ethic of autonomy
they would want to go further they would
want to talk
about the collective the community
this is the second moral theme the ethic
of community here the idea is that
people are
not simply isolated individuals
but rather that people find themselves
embedded
in larger groups right families
companies
towns churches nations and so on and in
fact
life as we know it would not be possible
without these communities therefore
folks in not western countries say
uh people have an obligation to align
their lives in such a way
that these communities can flourish
so it's it's not just me living my life
as i see fit
i have a duty to fulfill a place
in uh you know an institution
or a hierarchy where i am called to be
competent for the sake of my
my tribe uh my my people you know my
community
so that's that's the ethic of community
uh however
that would be kind of a whole other
sermon i'm not going to go into that one
a lot tonight
instead the one that really got me
thinking uh was
schweiter's third moral theme
and it is the ethic of divinity
this says that people are above all else
before they're part of a community
before
they're even kind of have a sense of
being an individual
people are carriers of
the divine image uh
call it the soul the divine spark call
it what you want but it's
it's language trying to grasp trying to
name this reality
to put it in more christian terms the
ethic of divinity is
basically is naming uh that we are
in some mysterious way called
into existence by god that we
are sustained in every moment by god's
spirit
in that when we die it is to god
that we return to be judged so this
ethic of divinity
also seems to be why there are certain
actions that we
interpret as moving us higher
so to speak um in other actions that we
interpret as
moving us lower and this is often where
we start to equate
you know good bad in other words there
are there are some things that seem to
draw us
upward toward the best versions of
ourselves towards the
the pinnacle of what humanity can be our
highest
ideals and values and ultimately i think
that's trying to grasp that language
like
up toward god while other actions do the
opposite
right other actions seem to move us
downward
down toward a more kind of base a sort
of reptilian
kind of almost animalistic you know
existence some actions seem to
um degrade us and this
moral theme is why
we don't eat our pets because
they trusted us to love them
in other words there are some things in
this world especially human beings
that are sacred and holy
and there are certain actions that move
us higher
while others move us lower even if
no one is hurt
which brings us back to the ten
commandments the ten commandments are
not
simply laws at least in the modern sense
of that word there is no
do the crime pay the time mentality
operating here there's really not a
utilitarian kind of cost benefit
analysis
being run here like someone who might
say would be like hmm
i mean maybe i should steal i mean if i
could get five million dollars
and then you know if i go to jail for
eight years
i mean it might be worth it uh like
no that's not that's not the 10
commandments that's not what's going on
here
uh i mean there are some vague
references to things like going better
or worse for you um you know kind of
depending on your actions
but it's not as clear as if you do thing
x or action y then you will go to jail
for ten years
that's that's not what the ten
commandments are about instead
i'm going to contend that the ten
commandments are deeply
rooted yes in all three of schweder's
moral themes
um you know autonomy uh community
divinity
uh but especially that third one
especially the ethic of divinity
and this is why i opened uh with a
statement you
are not a thing you
are a temple a house of divinity
in other words you are the place where
the holy spirit of god
dwells and and it's interesting to kind
of have this
framework and then like look at the
culture um
look at art and music and novels and
movies and kind of analyze like what's
going on here are they operating
um with any sort of ethic of divinity or
not
uh there's an old line i mean it's it's
super crass but it uh it just came back
to me from i guess
i think this band was like maybe big in
the 90s or the early 2000s
it's from my youth that's all i know uh
so i looked at i didn't even know who
sang this but it's the band the
bloodhound gang
um and so i think it's you know
vague enough that if we have any young
kids and not like catch on so
uh it says you and me baby we ain't
nothing but mammals
so let's do it like they do on the
discovery channel
uh yeah okay so what's that what's
missing there what's what's going on
what's missing is the ethic of divinity
in other words sometimes a thing is
wrong
not because anyone is hurt
but because it dishonors the image of
god in a person right it moves us
down towards a more unconscious
uh predatory maybe even like animal-like
existence
rather than upward towards the god who
is love okay so
why does this matter seems like a lot of
high falutin
ideas roaming around here like what does
this actually change
um let me try to help this kind of touch
ground here's here's what i've observed
in folks who go to similar types of
progressively churches
um like ours it's also something i've
observed in christians
who get super into politics both left
and right
um where like whether or not they
realize it they begin to use
purely western secular philosophical
arguments
to uh justify why a thing or a stance
is right or wrong so i'm not saying just
being you know into politics is terrible
i'm saying
it's when we kind of get in that mode
and
we um we start kind of basing our
politics on
western secular philosophical
assumptions um and then finally this is
also something and don't worry i'll name
it a second
this is also something i've observed in
those who are in the
throes of the deconstruction
of their faith right they just they
don't even know what to believe anymore
they're sort of reeling from doubt and
questions
and floundering around with what is
right and what is wrong and since to be
part of western culture
is to already be swimming in very
individualistic in quite secular waters
here's what happens
what happens is that we begin to let go
of the ethic of divinity
we begin to let go in
the world and all of creation
becomes less holy for
us less sacred
people including us become
less holy for us less
sacred and i'm not saying we do this on
purpose
it's not it's not a conscious process uh
we don't even know that we have done
that
but we have and again since to be part
of western culture
is to be part of a deeply
individualistic culture
uh we start to judge any moral issue
um that cannot be defended with an ethic
of autonomy we kind of start to judge it
as
um dumb and backwards and maybe wrong
i recall a conversation with a friend
i had many years ago and uh this isn't
anyone at the table
uh but they at this time they mostly
kind of left their christianity behind
at this point um
but they had been raised you know in
church and all that and so we were
talking um about a hypothetical
situation and the question was this
um what if your spouse uh like
you know passed away in some tragic
accident or something and
uh and i should mention this person they
they have been married um they were
married quite young
and uh and at that time they
were a christian and they had a really
like strong kind of sexual ethic growing
up so their you know their sexual
encounters pre-marriage were like very
minimal
uh so the question was what if your
spouse like passed away um
how would you handle that and
specifically how would you handle
you know dating and sex and and you know
all of that
and his answer honestly it kind of
shocked me
because he basically said uh oh well
i i think i just go a bit wild and i was
like oh
oh wow really uh why and
uh and he kind of described basically as
we unpacked a little bit more he was
talking about basically
lots of one-night stands and and i said
oh
okay uh interesting um
why you know and he said well
uh i mean why not
who cares not hurting anyone
and i was like huh and and i just sort
of we just kind of faded the
conversation
out and um it was a little bit awkward
but uh and by the way i should mention i
realize
um you know i'm i'm on kind of tricky
ground here because of all the
negative side to i get purity culture
and christian circles in the last you
know 30 years or so and
you know pre-marital sex or sex outside
marriage was often used to like shame
people make them feel dirty and terrible
um so that's not really my point
um but as i reflected on that
conversation
with my you know with my friend uh and i
i reflected on it as i was reading
heights book
and it occurred to me uh that what
this uh gentleman what he done
was um basically what he was using to
justify this idea of a string of you
know one night stands
um was really it was an ethic of
autonomy
right um because as he let go of his
christian faith
um what else had gone with it the ethic
of divinity
this idea that himself and other people
are holy and that even sex itself
is holy and not something to be engaged
in a
you know a sort of flippant just for the
sake of pleasure you know kind of
fashion in other words to be christian
is to operate with a very
deep and profound ethic of divinity
where people are not things
um people are not animals as that's
commonly understood animals right
they're not
uh walking meat suits uh
no like you are a temple
a house of divinity in fact
heck all of creation is a temple a house
of divinity it
is holy holy holy
and and this i i believe really is the
unspoken
foundation of the ten commandments
though you might say that it's not
completely unspoken i mean it's hinted
at
in the very structure of the
commandments themselves
uh just think of how do they begin the
first three commandments
are god god god uh
right you you shall have no other gods
before me
that's verse three you shall not make
for yourself an
image right an idol that's verse 4 you
shall not misuse
the name of the lord your god that's
verse
7 those are the first three in other
words god
is in god cares
how we think and how we relate back to
god
and then from that relationship that
connection to god
the other seven commandments having to
do with how we treat ourselves and other
people
they flow from there right how do we
relate
to sabbath rest um
to parents to sexuality
to stealing to um speech
and and the possessions of our neighbor
and how do we relate to them it all
flows from a very
god saturated way of viewing
the world it's it's an ethic of divinity
so in in short what i'm naming is that
as
christians i really think we need to
reclaim
this and and let's not
um in all of our doubt and
deconstructing
um move away from an ethic of divinity
heck if anything realize how much of
modern american christianity
has lost an ethic of divinity and then
respond to that like deconstruct
that in other words um see yourself
other people in the world as more
holy and and let's not in all our
thinking on politics
and all of our talking we do lots of
talking in baltics too
let's not only learn to speak
the moral grammar of
ethical autonomy in individualism
right i've got my rights uh even though
that is the only language you will hear
on all of the major news outlets
let's also learn to be fluent in the
ethic of community
and the ethic of divinity
and when we read the ten commandments
let's not
hear a bunch of heavy-handed
guilt-inducing statements about how
terrible we are
instead let's hear an invitation to see
the world
in a god infused way again a
call to ascend higher
so in closing here's here's a reflection
question
uh for you in this season of lent
that i'd like you to sit with for for a
moment and maybe as you go about this
evening
um so here it is what belief or
action have i been justifying
with an ethic of autonomy that an ethic
of divinity
might call into question so let me say
it again what belief or action
have i been justifying with an ethic of
autonomy in other words
who cares as long as i don't hurt anyone
that an ethic of divinity
right um might actually call
in to question um
all right let me pray for you lord jesus
i pray that you would
move us towards this very
god infused way of viewing the world
that the people around us would be
holy to us
and god where um we've based kind of our
whole view of the world
in in ethics of the individual would you
expand
us scott would you expand our
vision to include that but to move
beyond it
to see bigger god to care deeply for the
community
to care deeply for the divine image in
all things
god made that may that shift
may it do something really deep and
profound in us
so lord help us be a community of love
faith hope
and a deeply
good and kind people
just people um people who care
about others do that work in us lord in
christ's name i pray
amen
all right guys let's try this one more
time thumbs up if you can hear me
thumbs up if you can
okay it sounds like you guys can hear me
i'm getting i'm getting a message from
brett that says he can hear so i think
we're good
yes hopefully okay
so adam's giving thumbs up
all right um i'm gonna turn up
the mic a little bit just in case that
helps okay
all right um so one of the things i was
thinking when brett was telling me about
his message this week was
just that when i do engage this whole
um ethic of divinity when i do see
myself as kind of this vessel of god's
divine
life and spark and a place a person
where people are interacting and meeting
with jesus when they're interacting with
me the pieces of god that are deposited
in me are something that they are
experiencing
then i can also begin to acknowledge
and act and move with the spirit
of god and be a part of that restorative
redemptive work
in the earth um because suddenly i am
aware of the way that he
is working inside of me and the way that
my movement
my reactions my relationships
are a reflection of what he's doing
inside of me so
the song so will i came to mind because
it's just
always been one of those um the lyrics
have always just drawn me back
to this acknowledgement that i want to
be a part of
the ways that he has sown himself into
our world
the ways that hi the fibers of divinity
um are a part of of the stars that we
see
of the people that we love um
and we have an opportunity there to
carry out that divine love that divine
unconditional grace
and uh restoration here so
um yeah i i want to just take a moment
to do that song together as we
close out the service
[Music]
god of creation
they're at the start before the
beginning of
time
with no point of reference
you spoke to the dark and fleshed out
the wonders of
life
and as you speak
a hundred billion galaxies are born
in the vapor of your breath
the planets form
if the stars were made to worship souls
[Music]
fire of grace
if creation sings your praises
you don't speak in vain no syllable
empty
or void
for once you have spoken
all nature and science follow the sound
of your voice
and as you speak
a hundred billion creatures catch your
breath
evolving in pursuit of what you said
if it all reveals your nature
so will i
i can see your heart in everything you
say
every pain is
still obeys
if the stars are made
[Music]
if the ocean's
silence
billion times
[Music]
god of salvation
you chased down my heart through all of
my
failure and pride
[Music]
the light of the world abandoned in
darkness to
die
and as you speak
disappear
where you lost your life so i could find
it
here if you left
the grain behind you so
will i
i can see your heart in everything
you've done
[Music]
surrender so
i can see your heart a billion
different ways
every precious one a child
you came to save
if you gave your life to love
would them 100 billion times
but what measure could amount to your
desire
you're the one that never leaves the one
behind
thank you to mindy for
um all of that worship and
thank you to you guys for being here
with us tonight
thanks for joining in and um
i also just want to say thank you to our
ministry team leaders
our volunteers those who are still um
showing up every week to host meet ups
those who are giving financially i just
appreciate your faithfulness
in helping our community be one that's
effective
and that's truly getting the good news
of the gospel out there
um and um
if you were interested in the book club
that i mentioned
earlier um meeting on march 13th
feel free to comment below and just say
i'm interested please send me
information we
will reach out to you and make sure to
help you get connected to sarah and
glenda
um i know i also mentioned the state of
the table meeting that is tonight
6 15 we'll see anyone who's able over
there in a few minutes
sarah i believe is backstage and we'll
be posting the link for that
below and that is a google meets and we
are just really excited to
um touch base with all of you and uh to
see your faces as well and connect with
you again
um i am going to be sending you off with
a benediction
this is from 2nd peter and i actually
chose to read this from the message
tonight
starting in verse 2.
to you whose experience with god is as
life-changing
as ours all due to our god's
straight dealing and the intervention of
our god and savior jesus christ
grace and peace to you many times
over as you deepen in your experience
with our god and with jesus our lord
be blessed have a great week goodbye
you